43% of Americans say they're too tired
to function so odds are you're pretty
exhausted some mornings
you might even fantasize about staying
in bed forever hey look your wish came
true you got food a bed pan and it and
the stream of podcasts to binge
everything you need to never move again
but it won't be long until you realize
that you've made a terrible mistake
people spend lazy Sundays or sick days
in bed all the time and are no worse for
wear but if you don't start moving again
after about 24 hours one of the first
things to change is your lungs gravity
isn't pulling them down into their
normal position anymore so the lower
part of your lungs will crumble up you
probably won't feel any different but
watch out because it's harder for mucus
to pass through those collapse passages
so it can get trapped which can infect
your lungs and ultimately lead to
pneumonia that's why doctors tell people
on bedrest to sit up and COFF from time
to time
but you're way too engrossed in those
podcasts to remember to cough within a
week your problems only get worse you
see normally your muscles and bones help
support your weight under gravity but
now that you're lying down they're out
of a job and as the saying goes if you
don't use them you lose them for every
week in bed you lose about 1 percent of
your bone density making your bones more
brittle and easy to fracture
that's why astronauts who often go for
months without gravity exercise for at
least two hours a day and load up on
calcium in that same week you also lose
1% of your muscle mass particularly in
your thighs butt and shoulders which
you're no longer using now normally
those muscles would suck sugar from your
blood for energy to function
but after just 10 days of bed rest this
process slows down the result all of
that onion can build up in your
bloodstream and lead to type 2 diabetes
by week 2 you can start developing nasty
ulcers called bed sores these form when
the bony parts of your body like your
hips tailbone and ankles press against
the same spot for too long the constant
pressure blocks blood flow killing your
skin cells and if you're not careful
they can even rip through layers of skin
and tissue and expose your bones and
muscles which sounds like the opposite
of relaxing meanwhile those muscles are
wasting away faster than ever after just
two weeks you've lost a whopping 10% of
your muscle mass and that causes a new
problem because the less muscle you have
the less oxygen and therefore blood flow
they need so after a month in bed your
heart pumps 30% less blood per beat and
with less oxygen circulating through
your body you feel more tired even
though you've been resting for a solid
month and if you don't get up soon well
you're going to have a hard time ever
getting up again because six months
maybe a year in most of your muscles
have wasted away your bones are too weak
and fragile to bear your weight and your
heart isn't strong enough to do much
work anytime soon meanwhile your brain
isn't a happy camper either after all
you've been stuck in the same room for
months staring at the same walls the
same spot on the ceiling having the same
experiences day after day not great for
mental health to say the least
a study of pregnant women found that bed
rest increased their risk of anxiety and
depression and some women reported
feeling isolated out of control and
imprisoned
so no a year of uninterrupted bed rest
is not the relaxing paradise we'd all a
dream it'd be and this is exactly why
doctors try to get their patients up and
walking as quickly as possible
in the meantime medical staff turn
people every two hours to keep bed sores
at bay and encourage them to do
exercises in bed to get their heart and
muscles working so just keep in mind
there is nothing wrong with a lazy
Sunday morning as long as you're up and
moving before Monday strikes